[Musique]
si tu étais en asie serait quoi comme
nazi
elle est bonne celle là bun bruncher pas
je souhaite que cet ennui sinon j'aurais
dit n'est encore un riff de moi c'était
une infirmité
c'est quoi la vérité bien vite et les
choix
je suis déjà aveugle je voudrais avoir
laissé tout ce qui se passe dans ce
paysage c'est bien et si tu as été un
poison ciguë si du tout de suite tu
penses à ça des fois non
support avant on
pas trop ah bon j'ai pas d'argent à
l'hemingway le seul arme que tu es chez
toi c'est une seringue quoi et comme tu
la mets sur la table on pense pas que tu
t'en sers vraiment ont certes un gsm a
été donnée par le père de jane carrey la
dernière seuls les officiers blessés
avaient droit à cette seringue et une
ampoule de 100 films et 2e pompey doit
réguler souffrent qu'elle s'est vraiment
fait de bric et à cette offre
tous avaient les traits la perfide
albion est un accident vous est plus
arrivé bien le hindenburg là le truc
nazis qui s'est scratché sur new york
c'était du rap avant l'heure aujourd'hui
des sites étaient une cicatrice et un
tiers
hier sucre à m
voilà
tenez chier pour y arriver
avec les oiseaux
c'est dans le métier
il fauche prennent maintenant j'ai eu
beaucoup de blé cela me disais que tu es
beaucoup de blé non je pense que je vais
manger parfois je suis rouge
non c'est un grand chêne est un des
derniers grands chez germaine du 19 sec
tout dans les hautes alpes pour encore
voir les jets privés
c'était bien marré finalement à tanger
pas fini ah oui encore quelques bons
coups
mathieu avec bambou narré avec lui
foot de club dans l'oeil n'est pas un
jury s'est fait un shampoing riche en
humour assez bien le fils de son père y
est il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux